[Musique]
et avec nous aujourd'hui pour ce club
Michael Darmon qui s'installe bonjour
Michael merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
éditorialiste politique et Jefferson des
sports bonjour Jefferson bonjour merci
d'être là journaliste politique à
sud-ouest Alex nous a rejoint à
re-bonjour on parlera du rejet de la
motion de censure de justesse à 9 mois
près Elisabeth Bank peut-elle tenir à
Matignon l'exécutif est-il fragiliser
Emmanuel Macron va consulter toute la
journée on en parle la réforme des
retraites qui est donc adoptée par le
Parlement mais les opposants ne
désarment pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelle
à une censure populaire la contestation
va-t-elle se durcir vous ne direz ce que
vous en pensez d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions c'est
cette mobilisation qui a eu lieu dans
plusieurs villes du pays après l'annonce
du rejet de la motion de censure et
notamment à Lyon où on retrouve tout de
suite Alexis André plongeant Alexis
merci d'être avec nous directeur de la
publication de Lyon Mac comment s'est
passé la nuit du côté de Lyon Alexis
c'est encore été agité manifestation
sauvage hier soir à Lyon on commence à
être habitué parce qu'il y en a une
chaque jour depuis jeudi dernier hier 9
interpellations parmi plusieurs
centaines de manifestants du mobilier
urbain cassé des poubelles incendies et
puis ce matin il y a des barrages
filtrants un peu partout dans
l'agglomération pour distribuer des
tracts aux automobilistes on pense que
le mouvement va s'intensifier à Lyon
parce que les casseurs sont
systématiquement relâchés après leur
garde à vue ne seront jugés qu'à partir
de cet été
et puis une question peut-être un peu
plus politique Alexis est-ce que on a
des nouvelles du côté de Laurent
Wauquiez
non aucune nouvelle vous pensez qu'il
faut s'inquiéter il paraît vous savez
vous savez où il était il était en
immersion hier dans un hypermarché
Laurent Wauquiez fait des immersions en
ce moment il a fait les pompiers il a
fait les urgences c'est pour préparer
bien sûr 2027 s'immergé dans le
quotidien des Français mais sur le sujet
politique de l'année bien c'est silence
radio c'est à peine s'il avait indiqué
lors de ses vœux à la presse en janvier
que lui la réforme des retraites il
l'aurait pas fait tout à fait comme le
gouvernement Laurent Wauquiez l'a pris
tellement de coups en 2019 après l'échec
des républicains aux élections
européennes que désormais et bien ils
préfèrent jouer en coulisses il laisse
soigneusement le soin à Éric cieux
Olivier Marleix d'être en première ligne
le patron des républicains à l'assemblée
qui s'en était d'ailleurs indignés chez
nos confrères de RTL il demandait à
Laurent Wauquiez au président de la
Région verdonal d'être un peu plus
présent dans les débats nationaux il y a
pas eu de fronde anti Macron dans notre
région vous avez eu seulement deux
députés LR qui ont voté la motion de
censure du groupe liote hier il s'agit
de dinosineries dans la Loire et de
Fabrice brun en Ardèche
donc c'est sa stratégie Laurent Wauquiez
il donne l'impression de vouloir laisser
tout le monde s'échapper et d'attendre
le moment opportun pour débarquer tel un
chevalier blanc vierge de toute prise de
position polémique sauf qu'à à vouloir
laver plus blanc que blanc bah pour bien
finir par être transparent merci
beaucoup merci Alexia André d'avoir été
avec nous directeur de la publication de
Lyon Mag on regarde la Une de Lyon max
Vénissieux en quête sur un système dans
le rouge c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup on va parler des
républicains dans quelques instants mais
sur la première partie de l'intervention
d'Alexis c'est manifestation
mobilisation qui ont eu lieu dans
plusieurs villes de France et le cas
depuis plusieurs nuits mais
particulièrement hier après l'annonce du
rejet de la réforme est-ce qu'il faut
craindre une radicalisation est-ce que
l'exécutif craint une radicalisation de
ces mouvements amicales en tout cas il
observe est-ce qu'il a craint on verra
dans quelle mesure elle elle s'installe
on a vraiment l'impression de la sorte
de phénomène de soirée debout là qui est
en train de se mettre en place un peu
dans plusieurs villes de France je je
marquerais moins bémol vis-à-vis de la
comparaison avec les gilets jaunes c'est
pas exactement la même la même
motivation ça n'est pas la même manière
de se mobiliser ce ne sont pas les mêmes
les mêmes démarches qui existent là on
est focalisé sur le retrait du texte et
sur simplement le fait de protester et
de vouloir signifier à Emmanuel Macron
que la légitimité de la rue qui est
opposé à celle de du président et celle
du Parlement se fait entendre également
on verra dans quelle mesure elle
arrivera à faire pression donc pour
l'instant on est et j'ai le sentiment
que le l'exécutif paraît plutôt sur une
colère qu'un embrasement comme on peut
l'entendre mais on va voir comment c'est
effectivement cette colère dont 234 à
Paris est-ce que ça ça peut faire
changer la manière dont l'exécutive
voilà la suite
non ce n'est pas on n'est pas sur un
embrasement du pays quand même donc du
point de vue de l'exécutif je pense que
il y a le sentiment que c'est
maîtrisable qu'il faut laisser passer le
temps et enchaîner ce à quoi on est en
train d'assister en ce moment du côté du
gouvernement et du président Jefferson
vous êtes d'accord avec Michael on n'est
pas dans une gilet jauneisation de
il y a un vrai problème pour le
gouvernement on a bien vu que alors
c'est une épreuve de force mais c'est
aussi une épreuve dans le temps depuis
le début le gouvernement joue la montre
se dit que ça va passer mais là on sait
pas du tout où ça va il y a une volonté
en tout cas à la fois des oppositions et
des organisations des organisations
syndicales de ne rien lâcher et c'est
vraiment dans ce dans cette période là
où ça va se jouer et pour les
organisations syndicales et les
adversaires la réforme de retraite il
faut tenir le problème pour le
gouvernement c'est que il y avait ce
côté social mais maintenant il y a un
vrai problème politique puisque c'est
nevoit d'écart en parler ça ajoute un
surcroît de tension et c'était pas du
tout prévu on va en parler peut-être sur
le côté syndical Michael parler de ce
qui s'est passé hier à l'Assemblée
profond ressentiment à dire soir Laurent
Berger oui mais on sent bien que il
monte dans les termes au fur et à mesure
que sa capacité d'action se réduit en
réalité ça y est ils sont allés au bout
de leur travail ils ont organisé voilà
une mobilisation de manière forte de
manière calme digne assez imposante ils
ont repris la main par rapport
effectivement à cette époque des gilets
jaunes mais là le texte est passé et
on sent bien qu'il n'y a pas de il n'y
aura pas un rapport de force tel que on
rentrera dans une logique qui a été
celle du CPE il y a en 2005 en revanche
là où le il peut y avoir des coups de
théâtre c'est sur le chemin
institutionnel encore du texte le
Conseil constitutionnel peut censurer
des des certaines mesures en particulier
celles sur les CDI seniors et autres qui
n'ont pas leur place ou qui n'auraient
pas leur place dans un texte prévu pour
le financement de la sécurité sociale il
y a également on entend une forme de
possibilité pour que un feu vert doit
donner pour déclencher des
recueil une collègue de signature pour
un référendum d'initiative partagé ce
qui répond aux conséquence de bloquer la
promulgation du texte en quelques mois
donc de ce point de vue là c'est là que
effectivement les coups de théâtres
entre guillemets peuvent changer il y a
effectivement des recours juridiques
mais sur la mobilisation syndicale
est-ce qu'elle va vraiment s'essouffler
car on aurait pu prévoir un
essoufflement si jamais il y avait eu un
vote du texte ou alors un rejet de la
censure plus large mais le fait que le
gouvernement soit quand même passé en
force sur cette réforme des retraites et
soit passer in extremis de la censure ça
veut dire que quand même il y a quelques
questions qui se posent sur cette
procédure parlementaire et ça peut
peut-être relancer cette mobilisation
sociale il y a une grande manifestation
qui est prévue jeudi justement les
syndicats qui vont peut-être essayer de
prendre la et bien l'ensemble de
l'opposition à cette réforme maintenant
que une séquence parlementaire est
terminée d'ailleurs Jean-Luc Mélenchon
appelle à une censure populaire donc à
amplifier ce mouvement de manifestation
donc à voir si ce mouvement syndical va
s'essouffler toutes les difficultés
parce que les oppositions veulent gagner
dans la rue ce qu'elles n'ont pas gagné
dans les urnes c'est leur constat
d'échec on n'a jamais eu une assemblée
aussi représentative les Français ont
fait la proportionnelle avant qu'elles
ne soient votées et à l'arrivée on se
retrouve avec des oppositions qui sont
obligés de faire de déporter le débat
dans la rue c'est aussi leur échec de ce
point de vue là parce qu'ils n'ont pas
réussi à bâtir ses compromis au sein
même de l'Assemblée nationale et là il y
a un vrai problème et puis Mélenchon il
faisait propre navette je dirais entre
la rue et le Parlement il n'est pas au
Parlement donc là il récupère le texte
dans la rue et pour lui c'est évidemment
son moment donc
soit au balcon soit dans la rue donc
bien évidemment il doit il doit
maintenant continuer à animer mais la
réalité c'est que le carburant de la
capacité à mobiliser c'était le
cheminement parlementaire et est terminé
et les syndicats ils vont continuer de
faire quelque chose mais pas certain que
c'est un service à faire bouger le
gouvernement et on va revenir sur les
dernières heures de ce cheminement
parlementaire c'est assez donc joué à 9
voix Elisabeth borne échappe à la
censure la réforme des retraites et
désormais adoptée récit de ces dernières
heures agitées à l'Assemblée nationale
avec ses sites la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adoptée le sort du
texte des retraites ce sera joué à 9
mois près avec 278 voix sur les 287
nécessaires la motion de censure
défendue par Charles de Courson a été
rejeté à la tribune le député de la
Marne a déploré la méthode du
gouvernement pour faire passer ce texte
vous avez délibérément choisi cette
procédure pour préparer un éventuel
passage en force comment accepter un tel
mépris du Parlement comment accepter de
telles conditions d'examens sur un texte
qui aura des incidences durables sur la
vie de millions de nos compatriotes dans
sa réponse Elisabeth borne n'a pas
hésité à pointer les contradictions du
député et le comportement de la gauche
pendant les débats et quand je vois de
censure signée par toute la gauche mais
avec comme figure de proue un partisan
de la retraite à 64 ans comme le
proposait monsieur le député de Courson
votre amendement en octobre 2013
quelques minutes plus tard la motion
défendue par le RN a aussi été rejeté à
la sortie Marine Le Pen annonce qu'elle
fera un recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel
que nous allons saisir dès demain matin
pour demander la censure du texte à
défaut d'avoir obtenu l'ascenseur du
gouvernement les députés du PS demandent
eux la démission du gouvernement un
gouvernement qui est d'ores et déjà mort
aux yeux des Français qui n'a plus
aucune légitimité et évidemment une
première ministre qui n'a ni légitimité
ni pouvoir pour pouvoir continuer son
action et qui doit évidemment
démissionner en emportant sa réforme
avec elle Aurélien pralier chef de fil
des frondeurs LR espère que le vote
provoquera un électrochoc au
gouvernement le président de la
République a une responsabilité
rassembler la nation on ne que personne
ne pense que on va pouvoir continuer
comme ça sans que dans le pays il y a
des fractures qui peut-être demain ne
seront pas cicatrisables
l'exécutif a débuté des consultations
Emmanuel Macron recevra ce soir les
parlementaires de la majorité de faire
ça est-ce que l'exécutif est fragilisé
ce matin le gouvernement dans les cordes
et sa première ministre également ma
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi donc là il y a
un vrai problème parce que c'est neuf
voix d'écart c'était pas du tout le
scénario prévu depuis plusieurs jours la
majorité ne cesse de faire des décomptes
de voir où est-ce que ça va aboutir
comment ça peut atterrir cette notion de
censure là manifestement c'était
vraiment pas ce qui était prévu donc il
y a un problème pour le gouvernement il
y a un vrai problème politique parce que
le gouvernement est clairement fragilisé
est-ce qu'il est en sursis on a rarement
vu Emmanuel Macron réagir à chaud et
prendre des décisions il prend toujours
le temps lorsqu'il faut changer les
choses donc on verra combien de temps il
prendra justement mais là oui il y a un
vrai problème politique pour l'exécutif
des maintenant
la difficulté ça va être de réécrire
l'après c'est comme à quoi vont servir
ces consultations le chef de l'État doit
prendre la parole demain à 13h qu'est-ce
qu'il peut dire mais vraiment s'il se
pose en garant des institutions elle
doit aussi se poser en garant de l'ordre
social et d'être justement le ciment de
la Nation pour l'instant il y a trop de
fracture et il y a une vraie
partisibilité quand vous discutez avec
les députés de la majorité ils ne savent
pas du tout où ils vont il y a même une
vraie pointe d'amertume dans toute la
méthode et dans toute cette séquence
c'est un exécutif fragilisé avant de
parler de la majorité c'est un exécutif
qui est fragilisé Elisabeth borne et
fragilisé ce matin elle est fragile mais
pas fragilisée
c'est à dire que à l'heure actuelle il y
a pas d'autres solutions parce que
changer de gouvernement pourquoi faire
d'abord les Françaises s'en moque un peu
c'est pas leur sujet
c'est leur vie c'est pas du tout une
escouade d'inconnu qui va changer leur
vie à part de trois personnes voilà
après la question c'est politiquement si
on doit changer de gouvernement s'il y a
un gouvernement qui doit se mettre en
place nouveau c'est pourquoi faire il y
avait quel accord politique et c'est là
l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est qu'il y aille voir
une tentative et je pense qu'elle a déjà
démarré de la part d'Emmanuel Macron de
de d'avoir ce fameux accord du
gouvernement avec une partie de cette
droite qui a montré sa capacité ou son
envie à gouverner ou travailler sur
certains textes avec avec l'exécutif ce
qui provoquera encore plus l'explosion
donc du côté de du côté de la droite de
ce point de vue là on sait que dansait
déjà Bruno retail Bro de retaille est
opposé du côté général chez il le
souhaite plutôt
du côté du parti chez les ils sont
tellement divisés on se réunir ce matin
ils vont tenté de le voir la réalité
c'est que pour l'exécutif et pour
Emmanuel Macron qui qui est rentré dans
la scénographie habituelle de
consultation d'intervention à la
télévision peut-être de mea culpa ça
m'étonnerait mais on verra bien c'est au
fond un exercice assez connu mais qui
pour l'instant ne peut pas donner de
résultats probants et on va parler
derrière dans quelques instants mais sur
l'exécutif le gouvernement du calendrier
du gouvernement aussi quelle réforme
suivantes le gouvernement va pouvoir
faire passer il y a le texte immigration
qui est arrive la semaine prochaine au
Sénat alors la droite sénatale va voter
mais à l'Assemblée nationale il n'y a
pas de majorité et la majorité
présidentielle par le même d'un abandon
du texte au moment de l'étape de
l'assemblée puis après il y a une loi
on va le voter en durcissant et puis
après il y a la loi travail comment
Emmanuel Macron va pouvoir faire une loi
travail alors que il n'a pas parlé au
syndicat sur cette réforme des retraites
que le dialogue est le dialogue social
est coupé donc ça paraît très compliqué
d'une majorité relative voilà avec cette
séquence des retraites le gouvernement a
perdu son partenaire numéro un qui était
la droite elle c'est le gouvernement
s'est mis dans la main de la droite
entièrement jusqu'à épouser c'est Théo
c'est propositions de prendre reprendre
la droite c'est les propositions de la
droite sénatoriale sur la forme de
retraite et à l'arrivée elle se fait
lâcher par la droite par le montant à
l'Assemblée nationale donc son
partenaire quand on est dans une
majorité relative là il y a une impasse
avant de parler DLR est-ce que cette
séquence elle a coupé le lien en tout
cas la fragiliser le lien entre Emmanuel
Macron et Elisabeth borne et leur
majorité parlementaire elle a coupé le
lien entre le Président de la République
et sa majorité parlementaire Elizabeth
borne
voilà elle fait son travail d'Elisabeth
borne d'ailleurs elle-même c'est des
définies comme étant en fusible une
manière peut-être de se prolonger un
petit peu à ce poste là mais en réalité
le sujet n'est pas là le sujet c'est le
lien entre Macron et une majorité
parlementaire qui l'a jamais vraiment
trop pris en estime de ce point là c'est
aussi le prix à payer pour cette
majorité de gérer cette ambiguïté
matricielle du en même temps
Emmanuel Macron doit comprendre enfin
qu'il faut qu'il arrête c'est en même
temps s'il veut pouvoir continuer à
gouverner encore 4 ans parce que on voit
bien que tu as tout se passe avec la
droite tout ne peut se passer qu'avec la
droite faire croire aux Français que il
peut y avoir des majorités de projets on
voit bien l'échec absolu de cette de
cette méthode donc s'il n'y a pas je
dirais voilà un vrai changement dans la
pratique du pouvoir et sa conception et
son approche les choses continueront à
être comme celle-là donc au fond c'est
Macron qui doit montrer sa capacité à
avoir à entendre à comprendre voilà voir
que c'est souvent ces analyses sont
ratées les paris sont faux et que le
dispositif politique autour de
batignolisés est extrêmement faible
ouais parce que hier on a entendu au
Robert gélisabeth borne à la tribune de
l'hémicycle vanter cette majorité
parlementaire unie qui fait front qui
est solide est-ce réellement le cas de
faire les résultats c'est neuf voix
d'écart montrent encore une fois que il
y a une absence de majorité en tout cas
cette majorité relative est plus courte
que jamais plus rétréci mais cette
notion trans partisane sur les trois
groupes horizons modem Renaissance
est-ce que cette majorité ou est-ce que
là il y a un problème il y a un tous
depuis 2017 c'est Emmanuel Macron le
lien direct il est entre sa majorité il
était entre la majorité et l'Élysée les
députés en 2017 lors du premier
quinquennat ne cessait de nous dire ils
n'ont que des comptes à rendre à
Emmanuel Macron c'était Édouard Philippe
le Premier ministre pour à l'époque et
déjà Édouard Philippe donnait beaucoup
de boutons au député de sa majorité et
le lien a été plutôt comme ça
aujourd'hui ce lien entre le Président
de la République la majorité
préalablement terre lui est clairement
abîmé des députés hier soir ne cachait
pas encore une fois leur amertume ils
ont donné des signaux d'alerte ils ont
arrêté ils ont alerté sur le risque
social personne n'a écouté et en tout
cas à l'Elysée il n'y a pas eu d'écoute
sur ce point-là donc là il y a une
difficulté mais si on revient sur la
mention de trans partisane qui a été
présentée pour faire le lien est ce que
disait Michael sur le en même temps là
on a eu presque une leçon de macronisme
à l'envers on a eu des députés LR mêler
leur voix à des députés de la nupesse
des insoumis des socialistes des
écologistes et du rassemblement national
là on a eu une motion qui a réinventé le
macronisme sous une autre forme un peu
baroque certes bancaire mais on a vu
différents partis qui n'ont absolument
rien en commun s'associer s'allier
contre cette contre le gouvernement et
la majorité présidentielle donc là il y
a une leçon ils ont réussi à dépasser
l’écrivage et Charles de Courson un
fustigé hier notamment par Elisabeth
borne lui qui a voté la réforme de 2010
et qui prenait le report de l'âge à 64
ans il n'y a pas si longtemps oui et qui
c'était aussi prononcer contre le
mariage pour tous donc on était on était
pas un incohérence près parce qu'on est
dans une logique de jeu de jeu
parlementaires mais quelque part voilà
il a fait son il a eu son moment qui
avait d'ailleurs commencé Emmanuel
Macron l'avait désigné en septembre à la
télévision en disant qu'il y avait
peut-être un accord politique à passer
avec eux ce petit groupe c'est la
première fois vraiment comprenez
conscience de son existence il a fait un
autre trajet il a quand même servi de
révélateur à cette à cette gérée matrice
politique qui est arrivée à bout de
souffle et tout de même les
scénographies à laquelle on assiste
aujourd'hui on la connaît par cœur voilà
Emmanuel Macron qui consulte quand la
crise et là alors qu'il avait été
prévenu avant qu'il n'a pas écouté on
connaît les députés qui vont arriver en
allant qui vont sortir enthousiaste de
l'Elysée on connaît parce qu'ils vont
dire ils nous ont il a donné le cap on a
compris il nous a entendu tout ça on
connaît mais les Français aujourd'hui
sont ailleurs et la réalité politique
elle est que s'il n'y a pas d'accord
avec une partie de la droite et bien la
capacité à
gouverner tout simplement de cette
exécutif s'arrêtera la difficulté pour
les députés de la majorité c'est qu'ils
savent très bien que Emmanuel Macron ne
se représentera pas et la séquence
d'hier c'était quand même l'après Macron
qui s'est dessiné Olivier Marleix La Vie
Claire très clairement il a ouvert cette
porte là et en fait chacun est déjà
tourner vers 2027 mais les pour les
députés de la majorité ce sera sans
Emmanuel Macron et pour eux tout le défi
c'est que ce quinquennat ne soit pas une
un fiasco parce que sinon il n'y aura
pas d'après et tout s'arrêtera avec le
départ d'Emmanuel Macron de l'Élysée et
c'est la même problématique pour tout
les ministres de poids dans ce
gouvernement si jamais cela vire au
fiasco leur avenir personnel s'arrête
également en même temps c'est déjà acté
on sait que le macronisme c'est Emmanuel
Macron donc à partir et on le voit tous
les jours donc à partir de là et on sait
très bien puisque il y a aussi une
histoire dans l'histoire avec ce moment
terre qu'est-ce que sont les tensions
très fortes entre horizon et Renaissance
par son on sait que le projet
sous-jacent jamais jamais assumé jamais
jamais avoué c'est d'empêcher Édouard
Philippe du côté de du côté d'Emmanuel
Macron donc de ce point de vue là c'est
très tendu on l'a vu il y a des ça a été
raconté documenté il y a un escarmouche
une guerre d'usure permanente entre
raison et Renaissance parce que la
bataille pour le supposer
héritage du de du bacronisme on ce qu'il
en restera a déjà commencé donc de ce
point de vue là c'est aussi ce que ce
moment a montré on va parler de la
droite vous en avez un petit peu parlé
puisque si le résultat était aussi serré
c'est parce que plusieurs de nombreux
députés LR ont voté la motion de censure
d'émotion de censure qui ont continué de
diviser les halles à 19 députés les
républicains n'ont pas suivi la consigne
de leur partie et ont voté pour la
motion de censure transpartisanes du
groupe lyaute parmi eux on compte
évidemment Aurélien Pradier le député du
lot qui avait emmené depuis des mois
cette fronde contre la réforme des
retraites certains de ces lieutenants
aussi ont voté pour comme Raphaël sirène
berger Pierre-Henri Dumont Yann Boucard
mais aussi des indécis qui ont décidé
d'apporter leur voix à cette motion à la
dernière minute comme Emmanuel Antoine
député de la Drôme et puis des proches
de Laurent Wauquiez qui a annoncé par
Alexi comme le futur candidat de la
droite en 2027 par exemple Dino a
signéré député de la Loire et Isabelle
Valentin député de la Haute-Loire dont
Laurent Wauquiez est quand même le
suppléant donc il s’appelle Valentin qui
a voté pour cette motion de censure et
donc parmi ces 19 députés LR trois
d'entre eux ont aussi voté pour la
motion déposer par le rassemblement
national alors face à cette fronde de
ces députés LR et bien Éric utile patron
du parti a cherché hier soir à
relativiser ecouter la censure n'a pas
été approuvée par une très large
majorité des députés LR conformément à
ce que nous avions souhaité ce que
j'avais souhaité les républicains ont
fait peur œuvre de cohérence de
responsabilité
qui est minimise mais c'est quand même
un tiers du groupe LR à l'assemblée qui
a voté pour la censure du gouvernement
d'Elizabeth borne alors sur le fond
pourquoi c'est député l'ont fait pour
sanctionner le gouvernement mais aussi
un petit peu pour sanctionner la
direction des républicains écoutez
Pierre-Henri Dumont
de la réforme des retraites pour le
gouvernement d'abord peut-être aussi un
petit peu pour les républicains c'est
peut-être un problème de méthode et que
peut-être que demain ça veut dire qu'on
doit beaucoup plus travailler en amont
arrêter d'avoir des propositions qui ont
fait depuis 10 ans et qui n'ont pas
remporté suffrage des Français et
continuer de les mettre sur la table de
façon inlassable en espérant que cette
fois-ci les Français comprennent et puis
d'autre part faire en sorte que sur la
méthode on discute d'abord au sein du
bureau politique des républicains
d'abord au sein du groupe les
républicains à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat et qu'on met tout le monde
d'accord avant d'aller négocier avec la
première ministre avant d'aller discuter
sur ce qu'on veut ou ce qu'on veut pas
dans tel ou tel projet loi plutôt que de
faire l'inverse alors maintenant une
question se pose faut-il exclure ces
députés LR du parti c'est députés qui
ont voté la censure la question est
posée notamment par certains sénateurs
de droite et notamment vis-à-vis
d'Aurélien Pradier qui a mené qui a fait
péricliter finalement cette alliance
entre la droite et le gouvernement sur
cette réforme des retraites notamment à
cause de ces mesures d'amélioration qui
demandaient sur les carrières longues
alors Aurélien Prady a-t-il peur d'une
exclusion la question lui a été posée
par nos confrères LCP
ce que vous redoutez d'être exclu des
républicains franchement vous pensez que
c'est un sujet qui me préoccupe
aujourd'hui d'abord nous sommes près
d'une vingtaine de députés à avoir voté
la motion de censure bon je veux bien
que on se focalise toujours un peu sur
moi mais c'est pas tout à fait une
aventure individuelle ça veut dire
quelque chose y compris des
questionnements que la droite doit avoir
moi je suis fier d'avoir participé avec
près de 20 de mes collègues au fait de
porter aussi la voix du peuple je ne
veux pas laisser le soin de porter la
voix du peuple aux extrêmes à l'extrême
droite à l'extrême gauche je pense que
la droite à le faire mais vous savez la
reconstruction de la droite c'est un
long chemin un peu moins important
beaucoup moins important que la
reconstruction de notre pays on a pu
noter que le numéro 2 du parti
François-Xavier Bellamy l'a dit il y a
quelques minutes sur notre antenne
l'exclusion de ces députés LR n'est pas
la solution et puis leur partie n'en a
pas les moyens
ce sont les grands perdants de cette
séquence Michael Darmon pour vous le
grand démantèlement continue
et il va s'accentuer notamment si
effectivement pour sortir de la crise
Emmanuel Macron met sur la table une
proposition d'accord de gouvernement je
crois que l'exclusion effectivement de
des frondeurs de d'Aurélien Pradet pas
de Pradier de ces troupes au fond n'est
pas tant le sujet que leur propre
décision de partir en cas de d'accord
éventuel avec le gouvernement
c'est pas fait parce qu'il faut que les
instances du parti décident on l'a dit
tout à l'heure pour une Retailleau et
contre du côté de certainement de la vie
voilà du côté de rachelette si on est
plutôt pour parce que évidemment elle
est poussée par Nicolas Sarkozy qui a
derrière nous pousse les feux donc de ce
point de vue là on est dans je dirais un
feu qui continue à avancer et qui est en
train de continuer à brûler
la poutre travaille encore comme alors
Philippe je sais pas si elle travaille
en tout cas le travail pas bien mais le
grand perdant c'est quand même d'abord
le gouvernement ensuite pour la droite
les divisions qui sont qui sont apparues
ces fractures là montrent aussi une
chose c'est que ces députés frondeurs et
c'est assez savoureux d'avoir des
fondeurs chez LR et avoir cette
expression là bien entendu mais en tout
cas ça montre une chose c'est qu'ils ont
d'abord été élu sur leur nom et moins
par l'étiquette LR c'est plus
l'étiquette LR qui est porteuse en tout
cas sur les dernières législatives c'est
ce qu'on a vu donc ils ont une très
grande liberté une très grande autonomie
vis-à-vis de la direction des
républicains et leurs critiques quand on
discute avec eux sont extrêmement
acerbes l'un d'entre eux me disait hier
pour qu'il y ait les gens au chef il
faut encore faut-il qu'il y ait un chef
sous-entendu
Eric Ciotti ne fait pas ne fait pas le
job et l'incarne pas la suite donc les
les regards se tournent vers le renvoie
ok mais on l'a dit sur votre plateau il
est extrêmement silencieux donc pour les
républicains oui il y a un vrai problème
ils peuvent pas les exclure sinon ils
vont se retrouver à 40 et là ça pèse
plus rien mais le problème c'est que en
2017 pendant le premier quinquennat je
reviens toujours là-dessus mais il faut
avoir un peu de référence l'obsession en
tout cas la pri les macronistes c’était
quand même de faire exploser la droite
définitivement ils sont presque arrivés
là ils y sont ça y est c'est fait la
droite va exploser mais le problème
c'est qu'il y a les emmène avec eux donc
ça arrive un peu trop tard dans le
calendrier initial parce que la
clarification aurait pu se faire avant
la présidence et là tout allait mieux
les LR macrocompatibles partaient
directement la droite explosée et pour
la majorité et tout ça allait bien le
scénario se fait mal et tout le monde en
paye les pots cassés de la direction de
LR jusqu'à l'Élysée et avec une fracture
nouvelle et très puissante entre l'air
du Sénat et les LR du Parlement on
évoquait tout à l'heure sur le texte
immigration qui voilà et elle va être le
texte de la droite sénatoriale ça on le
on le sait bien sauf que du côté du
Parlement il va avoir une tentation de
dire cette fois-ci on va montrer qu'on
n'est pas du côté du gouvernement
peut-être et de ce point de vue là va y
avoir une assemblée
il va y avoir une tension et une envie
de se radicaliser encore plus pour
pouvoir faire oublier l'épisode de
retrait donc demander dans dans les
paradoxes des incohérences les jeux qui
au fond une fois de plus sont très très
loin des préoccupations des Français
l’incohérence par nos incohérence c'est
quand même manifeste parce qu'on a quand
même des députés de droite qui ont
soutenu Vala iprès à la présidentielle
qui soutenait les 65 ans et là
subitement les 64 ans sont devenus une
brutalité donc vis-à-vis de leur
électorat que la droite
perdent sa boussole sur une réforme des
retraites avec une mesure d'âge ça reste
quand même assez lunaire et là pour
reconstruire sur des bases comme ça et
pouvoir se présenter comme des députés
responsables et cohérents là je pense
qu'il va y avoir un petit un petit
travail à faire et du coup on a d'un
côté Bruno Le Maire qui appelle les
républicains qui ont soutenu la réforme
des retraites à venir travailler avec le
gouvernement gendarella lui qui fait les
yeux doux à ceux qui ont voté la motion
de censure est-ce qu'on en revient au
clivage chez l'air bon on revient à
l'équation
du début de ce deuxième voilà de ce
deuxième mandat de d'Emmanuel Macron
pour du point de vue de LR
soit ils sont remplacés par les
macronistes ils sont remplacés par les
le pénis et vous vraisemblablement ça va
encore bouger pendant quelques pendant
pendant quelques années il y a
évidemment aussi un enjeu de du rôle
d'Éric ciotique qui a été qui a mené une
campagne sur une droite décomplexée et
dont le premier acte politique aura été
d'aider le gouvernement donc de ce
point-là c'est pas étonnant qu'il est
provoqué effectivement autant de de
clivage compte tenu qu'effectivement
comme on l'a dit les députés se sont
fait élire sur leur nom et non pas sur
l'étiquette mais c'est intéressant parce
que le clivage actuel de la droite qui
est cartelée entre le gouvernement et le
rassemblement national il est pas tant
sur les questions de sécurité
d'immigration de laïcité c'était un
clivage passé qu'on a connu entre la
droite modérée et la droite des
complexées mais il est sur la question
sociale avec ces jeunes députés LR qui
disent faut qu'on arrête de proposer ces
grandes réformes libérales ces grandes
coupes sombres qu'on propose depuis 10
ans et que le peuple ne veut pas il faut
qu'on devienne vraiment une droite
populaire
avec des réformes sociales et finalement
c'est une fibre sociale qui est aussi
travaillé du côté du rassemblement
national à une jambe sociale et une
jambe sur le régalien qui est plutôt
très dur et sur la suite maintenant du
texte puisque la réforme a été adoptée
Emmanuel Macron doit prendre la parole
demain est-ce qu'il peut retirer le
texte selon vous Michael il est
président de la République il peut
retirer le texte qu'on a vu pour le
politiquement non
personnellement dans son schéma
personnel non plus bien évidemment je
pense qu'il va aller défendre défendre
au contraire le texte fustiger une
partie de de
des parlementaires des élus et députés
qui ont empêché le débat et continuer
voilà de à dire que il faut avancer
continuer à réformer justifier aussi sur
le plan financier et son plan des
marchés financiers puisque finalement à
la fin la vraie raison cette réforme de
retraite a été quand même au fond assumé
c'est une réforme financière pour
montrer aussi au marché que la France
reste crédible et de ce point de vue là
il va falloir trouver un moyen surtout
c'est la mission peut-être la plus
compliquée de tenter de renouer un lien
avec les Français c'est tout le problème
pour Emmanuel Macron parce que certes le
problème du texte mais ce texte il
montre quoi encore une fois une pratique
du pouvoir qui a été critiquée c'était
le mouvement des gilets jaunes c'était
ça a été à de nombreuses reprises mais
là on est encore au même point c'est à
dire que on a un président qui n'écoute
ni sa majorité ni les alertes qui
viennent du des syndicats et pourtant au
soir de sa réélection il l'avait dit ce
vote m'oblige on avait compris qu'il y
aurait une nouvelle méthode on aurait
compris qu'il y aurait moins de
verticalité que ce serait beaucoup plus
partagé c'était aussi le discours de
politique générale de l'isabet laborne
il y aurait du compromis de l'ouverture
et Charles de Courson hier n'a pas
manqué de le rappeler devant les regards
exaspérés d'Elizabeth borne donc on en
est toujours au même point d'une
pratique politique qui fait débat et qui
en tout cas met une partie des opposants
du texte dans la rue donc pour le
président de la République c'est comment
il se réinvente qu'est-ce qu'il va
pouvoir proposer mais la vraie question
elle est autour de lui aujourd'hui mais
ce qui peut encore se réinventer est-ce
que c'est pas sa personne finalement qui
cristallise les tensions et le rejet des
Français plus que sa politique oui parce
que il est dans une logique et dans une
approche de je dirais de des solutions à
apporter qui
considère que elles sont chez lui qu'il
a raison qu'il a compris et que si les
Français ne le méritent pas c'est pas
son problème et que et au fond c'est un
petit peu ce que l'on comprend à travers
son positionnement et son comportement
depuis sa réélection et de ce point de
vue là on a du mal à comprendre et
beaucoup le disent aussi autour de lui
ont du mal à dessiner vraiment le ce
caisse ce nouveau et dernier mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron il nous reste 20
secondes
la retraite il n'envisage pas de quitter
l'Élysée sans avoir fait la mère de
réformes c'est-à-dire la réforme des
retraites il a pas pu le faire lors de
son premier quinquennat à cause de la
crise covid dans son souvenir mais
finalement ce qu'on est en train de
vivre là c'est 112 cours et vécu Édouard
Philippe parce qu'on l'a oublié en 2018
2020 quand la réforme des retraites à
points se prépare on est déjà dans un
moment de cristallisation dans un moment
de tension et il se prépare lui aussi un
auto un printemps social explosif la
crise du covid bah là tout ça Édouard
Philippe sort plus populaire que jamais
de Matignon mais l'histoire n'aurait pas
dû être celle-ci et celle qu'on a pas
vécu on l'a vu aujourd'hui on continue à
parler de ces notions de censure c'est
évidemment la une de vos journées
régionaux ce matin
[Musique]
et Alex l'émotion de censure font la une
de la presse régionale sans exception
l'émotion de censure ce sont à la une de
toutes les de toutes la presse régionale
l'émotion rejetée la réforme adoptée à
la ligne de l'Alsace ne voit et 64 ans
j'ai bien aimé un styles personnellement
à neuf ou après à s'exclame le Dauphiné
Libéré une réforme des retraites qui
passent sur un fil titre le journal La
Provence et un gouvernement sauvé de
justesse hier soir la première ministre
Elisabeth borne a accueilli je cite avec
humilité et gravité ce vote et estime
que le pays est arrivé au bout du
cheminement démocratique d'une réforme
de retraite essentielle pour le pays
comme s'il fallait tourner la page et
pourtant Elisabeth borne sort de cette
séquence extrêmement fragilisée c'est ce
qui ressort aussi dans la presse
régionale ce matin le gouvernement dans
la passe dans l'impasse à la Une de La
Dépêche du Midi la grande incertitude
titre l'Union une réforme mais à quel
prix politique se demande le mail libre
à la première ministre est discrédité
estime le journal Libération champagne
une première liste discrédité après être
passé en force en utilisant on le
rappelle le 49.3 sur la réforme des
retraites à l'Assemblée nationale une
réforme dont une majorité de Français ne
veut pas la balle est désormais dans le
camp d'Emmanuel Macron pour maintenir en
poste ou non Elisabeth borne et pour
donner un nouveau souffle à son
quinquennat son gouvernement va-t-on
vers un nouveau remaniement seul le
locataire de l'Élysée à pour l'instant
la réponse et malgré l'adoption de la
réforme des retraites la mobilisation
sociale ne va pas diminuer ce rejet de
la censure est donc l'adoption du texte
et du ravaler pour les manifestants
opposés à ce texte elle a une de
Sud-Ouest réforme adoptée la réagit à la
Une des Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace
elle censure se fera-t-elle dans la rue
c'est ce que se demande le journal
Nice-Matin alors qu'hier soir il y avait
des manifestations dans tout le pays et
des rassemblements qui ont été parfois
émaillés de violence et d'affrontements
entre des casseurs et des forces de
l'ordre les syndicats craignent une
radicalisation de la mobilisation et
pointe a déjà la responsabilité
d'Emmanuel Macron dans ce climat social
merci beaucoup Alex Jefferson regarde la
Une de Sud-Ouest motion de censure un
rejet dur à avaler oui on en a parlé
effectivement du ravalé pour la majorité
du ravalais pour les opposants au texte
parce que c'est passé tout près 9 voies
d'écart on l'a dit sur ce plateau
à l'épreuve du pouvoir l'homme derrière
le sapin ça sort le 24 mars voilà un
portrait à l'épreuve des faits du
nouveau maire de Bordeaux et lui en 2020
voilà qui est cet homme s'est écologiste
qui a pris à la suite en tout cas à la
mairie de Bordeaux au palais-rouan qui
s'est installé à la suite des
municipales que l'on connaît voilà c'est
un portrait à découvrir c'est qu'aucigné
avec mon camarade de Xavier Sota voilà
en librairie dès le 24 mars voilà et ça
sort donc ce vendredi merci merci
d'être venu merci beaucoup Michael
Darmon d'être venu dans ce club merci
Alex nous on se retrouve demain et
évidemment on continuera à parler de
cette réforme des retraites et de ses
conséquences et puis on vous en parlerai
évidemment à 18h dans le sens unique
avec Thomas eu très bonne journée à
demain
[Musique]